Vous souvenez-vous de ce que vous faisiez
il y a 6 semaines ?
J’en suis sûr ! Il y a 6 semaines, nous étions le 17 mars
le jour du déclenchement du confinement.
Depuis cette date, vous avez changé.
Vous n’êtes plus tout à fait les mêmes.
Vous avez changé de peau.
Pas à la manière « The Mask »… Non !
En 6 semaines, parfois un peu moins,
vous avez entièrement renouvelé
l’enveloppe qui recouvre votre corps.
La peau est l’organe
le plus important du corps humain : 2m2.
Elle est constituée de 3 couches :
l’hypoderme, le derme et l’épiderme.
C’est l’épiderme qui se renouvelle.
Il est constitué de cellules qui se forment à sa base.
Les cellules se divisent et repoussent
celles qui se trouvent au-dessus.
Chaque fois qu‘une nouvelle cellule apparaît,
les plus anciennes remontent d’un cran.
Quand elles arrivent en surface, elles meurent
et forment la couche cornée
dont elles finissent par se séparer.
D’après les spécialistes, un adulte perdrait
et fabriquerait en moyenne 35 kg de peau par an.
Pas étonnant qu’on se sente aussi bien dedans.
C’est un éternel renouvellement,
comme les « capsules de déconfiné ».
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
les précédentes en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en publie une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Et n’oubliez surtout pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.